[Music]
we recently got invited to play I did
Dungeons & Dragons which is something
that you were into oh boy
oh well I here's what was sad I yes I
was very much into Dungeons and Dragons
in the 6th and 7th grade I love how I'm
saying it as if I matured I was into it
then as I got older I would still I kept
playing D&D until about my freshman year
of high school and then it just got so
crazy elaborate we wanted to include
every movie then then you fall into the
Bladerunner universe or they know I
don't want to be in the we wanted to put
everything so then his next level nerd
sub and the road warrior shows up I'm on
a dragon on a wall you don't car so I'm
Captain Planet well yeah it was yeah
then the disturbance from upstairs
Downstairs but a few years ago before
before I had AI me and some adult
friends Brian Posehn blaine capatch
Chris Hardwick all were in a Dungeons
and Dragons group and we would go play
and I remember my wife saying I would be
she goes this is a the saddest midlife
crisis I've ever seen because I would be
less creeped out if you guys were just
going to strip clubs and I'm I secretly
am kind of hoping that I'll find out
that you're using this as a cover to
just go to strip clubs and get drunk
should be happy yeah that would make me
less wear than you're at a table just
like well I'm gonna so if the troll is
advancing I have a I guess I'll roll for
initiative now that I mentioned that I
have a plus 2 glyph of warding so I
would know she'd rather just you know My
milkshake brings all the boys and
like uncomfortable you come home covered
in some sort of Gator
yeah exact an host glitter the umber
Hulk attack you know but we actually
they told me that you have a photo of
you when you played the nd as a kind
yeah I do why somebody sent this to me
and then I put it up on Twitter and then
people send it got passed around a lot
so why don't we show this is me in the
sixth grade yeah very good
and I'm holding the The Player's
Handbook and she was like a rabbi with
his first tour he was really sad was
that a I've never been happier than I
have been in that photo ever yeah joy
yeah what happened no cure oh wait a
minute carbs
[Music]